did some of the sitting justices on the  supreme court lie about roe vs wade many  justices who are about to overturn roe  and casey swore that precedent was  settled and that principles of starry  decisis require roe vs wade to remain in  place if they were lying is there a  penalty will senator susan collins would  certainly be upset she said quote if  this leaked draft opinion is the final  decision and this reporting is accurate  it would be completely inconsistent with  what justice gorsuch and justice  kavanaugh said in their hearings and in  our meetings in my office the thing is  supreme court justices have life tenure  life tenure means life tenure and the  only remedy is impeachment which  basically has never happened in modern  history